DANNY: Lonny's been doing
an awesome job painting
cars for us for years, man.
And while his 1986 Lincoln
was always a beautiful car,
it was lacking that special
Count's Kustoms touch.
So not only did we
do some cool trunk
upgrades and some
cool stereo upgrades,
we came up with a wicked
paint job on this thing
and took it from
badass to world class.
Lonny is so excited
to show this car off.
He's brought along a good
buddy of his named Remo.
Now, Remo's been in
the lowrider industry
for a long time, a wicked
custom painter in his own right.
So we're going to show
this car off to Remo.
If we get his stamp of
approval, man, we have won.
How long have you been doing
the lowrider stuff, brother?
Over-- Over 10 years now.
Nice.
So he's got it running through
the veins like me and you.
- Absolutely.
- He's got the fever.
I think you're
going to dig it, bro.
You know, Remo, everybody here
worked really, really hard,
and there's a few
reasons why, man.
I mean, first off,
the car is a cool car.
It's a great project.
Second off, man,
Lonny is family.
He's a brother.
Third off, this dude is
so picky that everybody
had to come out swinging or
it was getting kicked back.
So I hope you dig this one.
- Absolutely.
REMO: I can't wait to see it.
Absolutely.
And, you know,
usually, this is my
point where I yell for
something to come out.
No.
Your car, you do it.
- Nice.
And if you don't
do this right,
I'll make you do it again.
I'll make you proud.
[danny laughs]
Go, brother.
Ryan, pull that beautiful
town car out, baby!
Check this out.
LONNY: Oowie.
Look at that grille.
Oh, man.
REMO: Ooh.
Nice.
REMO: Excuse my French,
but that's [bleep] badass.
LONNY: Look at that.
Look at that.
Look at the shine on that.
Look at the pinstripe on that.
Yeah.
DANNY: To transform
this car from a nice car
to a Count's Kustoms creation,
we went to town on this paint
job, adding pinstripes and a
classic lowrider scrollwork
to the already beautiful
blue base coat.
And he also threw in
a few extra touches
like the incredible water drops
on the trunk and on the hood.
With all that gorgeous
work that Ghetto Bob did
on that awesome custom
stereo system neatly hidden
with those friction-fit
covers in the trunk,
this thing is ready
for the show circuit.
I couldn't be prouder of my team
and of this beautiful Lincoln.
I think it's gorgeous, man.
I'm really happy with it.
This thing came out so sick.
I can't believe how well these
guys did for me this time.
Remo, what do you think?
REMO: It's better
than a Lincoln.
LONNY: That's right.
REMO: It's a Count's Lincoln.
[laughter]
The water drops, sick.
As a painter, I know
it's really, really
tricky to make outstanding water
drops on a dark base like this.
That's what's tripping me up.
I love the way you pinstripe.
Artwork style mixed
with this, the curves
of a lowrider scrolling style.
- Absolutely.
Beautiful.
LONNY: Yeah.
I wanted to keep it sleek
and elegant, you know?
Keep the old school
flavor on him.
And then, of course, the
hood matches the deck lid.
Over and under is on the top.
The finish on this car--
the clear coat is flawless.
LONNY: If you look real close,
just don't hurt yourself
on that nice hood ornament.
DANNY: Hold up a second.
I don't have one of these.
[lonny laughs]
Oh, and it's [inaudible]!
LONNY: Completely functional.
DANNY: I love that.
RYAN: Yeah, that's
beautiful [inaudible]..
DANNY: I got to have
that on my Lincoln now.
LONNY: And here's the
kicker right here, Remo.
The trunk.
It was a mess back there before.
We tucked it.
We cut it to fit.
No screws required.
It's just such cut out precision
that it just fits together.
I love the shapes
in all the panels.
Instead of leaving
them flat, just gave
a little edge or something.
Let's give all the
flavor [inaudible]..
This car it's-- it's you.
There's one more
thing I've got to show
you guys inside the garage.
Let's go check this out, man.
[music playing]
Closing this thing down?
What are you going to do?
Are you going to call your car?
I'm going to call my car.
Lights on.
No way.
[laughter]
Check you out, man.
Hey, this is for the
night's show, guys.
Let's go to strobe
light, please.
DANNY: Look at that.
And it changing colors?
Oh, dude.
Get down, man.
Dude, the grille?
LONNY: Yes, sir.
DANNY: Underneath?
DANNY: The wheel wells?
LONNY: Yes, sir.
Come on, man.
All phone operated.
DANNY: All from your phone?
That's cool that you
can talk to your ride
and make it do this
from your phone.
REMO: That's a
traditional lowrider
with a little modern twist.
Really good job, guys.
And, Lonny,
congratulations once again.
Thank you for
being there, man.
- I love it.
- This is beautiful.
Man, I'm so glad that we could
do something special for one
of my guys, and I got
to say, this Lincoln
came out just beautiful.
I'm proud to see this
thing parked in my parking
lot every day as long as
Lonny will hook me up with one
of them cool hood ornaments.
Right now, I think
he owes me a ride.
Well, Lonny, let's
go to the office.
I've got your bill waiting.
[laughter]
I'll be right there, boss!
Thank you.
- Absolutely, man.
- Thank you, Danny.
Absolutely.
Man, she's beautiful.